I understand you and your brother Tim
grew up in Annapolis Maryland that's
right how was it the movie-going
experience in Annapolis was it I think
it was I think it was normal I think it
was kind of your quintessential
small-town movie-going experience I
that's how I would spend my weekends I'd
go see one two maybe three movies a
weekend I was there's my favorite thing
to do and you know saw everything in the
theater or went to Blockbuster you know
I think I'm pretty sure every week there
were multiple blockbusters in our house
just on a on a cycle so that was the
weekend plan was just sort of movie
binge yeah yeah and sports and there
yeah movies were a huge part of it so
you came to West Hollywood I'm not sure
if you came there with your brother or
out of college in West Hollywood you
know yes he was here a couple years
before me but a year and a half before
me and he went he did a year at USC and
we both I came out right after college
and we both took jobs in the industry
and kind of as we figured out what
packed we wanted to go and what we
wanted to do and pretty early on we said
we're gonna do something pretty
audacious and we're gonna go out on our
own and try to make a movie and so that
was at the time was actually a different
film we were trying to get made before
jamesy boy and that film you know as you
as it goes it fell apart I never really
got off to a good start but we learned a
lot we met some people along the way and
I don't think jamesy boy would have
happened without the false start of the
previous project interesting but you
came out here having done a few short
films yeah like five or so you had I had
done a number of short films in college
and then had made two films two more
shorts when I came out here so my first
couple years out here I was still making
shorts what were the sort of person what
was the perception like of what was
going to happen to
younger guys in an apartment in West
Hollywood coming from a smaller town you
know it versus what actually happened so
what were your sort of expectations and
then what is your question
I don't I don't think I know the answer
to that I wish I could go back and think
about my mindset you know right out of
college but we were always very driven
you know we were always very determined
to achieve our goals and our goals were
making movies and so I don't think there
was ever a moment where we kind of said
we can't do this you know we just looked
at everything practically and said okay
this is the project we've gotten it
creatively there now what are the steps
that you know we need to make to get it
made and that kind of goes with every
project we do whether it's something
we're producing something I'm directing
and so I don't I don't think there was
ever a moment where I had this
perception and it wasn't met I loved it
I mean I love living out here and
California is very invigorating and
being in this town in this business
you're surrounded by super talented
people every day and it's it's inspiring
I love it
so you and Tim both had industry jobs
did that leave a lot of time for you to
get your production company off the
ground I mean I know a lot of times in
the beginning you're working very very
long hours - yeah you know I think when
we decided that we were going to do this
on our own we quit the industry jobs and
we did you know I picked up odd jobs
tutoring and coaching tennis and other
things to pay the bills as we tried to
build something and that took a long
time it really took a long time so let's
go back to James II boy did you know the
gentleman that the story was about
previously yeah oh you did yeah
he's actually staying with me right now
oh wow really dear friend of mine the
back story - that is quite amazing
because Tim and my mother is a filmmaker
as well
and a documentarian and she had done a
documentary back in 2001 called if I
could which focused on James the subject
of jamesy boy years younger and her MA
and his mother and their family story
and that movie also was a pickup of a
story that my mom had covered at CBS
News 20 years prior to that so there's
this long progression of this family
that we've tracked and told told their
story and they're really this incredible
story is people I mean they've they've
overcome so much I mean James is still
one of my inspirations and he's a
immensely talented filmmaker today
himself doing a lot of really exciting
work but yes oh I knew James and so I
was closed at the time that I started
developing the script I wasn't close
with him the process of doing the script
brought us really close together
when did you start is it star thrower or
demons
so when entertainment yeah an
entertainment I'm sorry we started that
officially probably about six years ago
but it existed prior the name existed
the idea of it existed just not as
formally as it does today but yet we
started it about five and a half six
years ago and with a focus on
development we wanted to to develop
projects from inception hire writers
give ideas birth and and then take them
out to packaged and look for financing
and you know the traditional producing
route and so that's what star thrower
started as and it's still to this day
what it the company is primarily focused
on do you mind if I ask how much money
does it take to start a film production
company I mean you're taking these odd
jobs your tennis lessons and the after
sure it's not quite as easy to pin one
number on it it takes enough to to back
up you know to hire writers really
that's what it took its hook enough to
go out there and be able to hire writers
and on ideas that you believe have
viability
and that you believe you can get there
and so that's what we did that's really
how the company started I want to talk
about crooked somebody in just a second
but I wanted to ask you about you said
there was another project that didn't
get made that jamesy boy ended up
getting me that you learned from what
were those lessons that maybe saved you
with jamesy boy that cost you with the
other great question a lot of it had to
do with understanding budget you know
they're there that movie required
something larger it required a bigger
presence in as a first-time filmmaker
and a young one at that with a script
the script had won the nickel fellowship
so it was something that was out there
and it was a really beautiful script
talented writer wrote it but it we
believed it had commercial viability
because it felt like a big broad movie
that you could see on many theaters when
in actuality I think independents are
better served when they offer counter
programming to what the studios are
offering and so we just really found it
hard to attach talent and to raise money
and I think when we looked at the time
when we were looking inward we were
saying this is too far of a mountain to
climb and we said okay if we do this
again and start over how do we choose a
subject matter that is grittier feels
like it works in that independent space
that can be produced for less money so
those were all the things we kind of
factored into that equation so maybe too
ambitious of a budget and realized that
it was more about story and focusing so
I think it needed too much to get that
made for our first-timer and not not to
mention you know it takes place on an
island and 20 percent of the movie was
out on a sailboat and that all these
things that really would have been tough
for an experienced filmmaker let alone
someone who'd never done a feature and
you were sort of the co-writer of two
I co-writer of James II boy it's not as
the original right right okay but I
don't see writing as a I don't think I'm
a great writer I think I think there are
better writers out there to execute a
vision or an idea so what drew you to
crooked somebody what what was the how
did you hear about it script so rich
Sommer and I had done a movie the prior
summer together that I'd produced called
LBJ and rich was in that and we became
good buddies on that set and he was
telling me about an idea that he had for
a movie and his best friend from college
Andy zilch and results who who wrote the
script was writing it for rich and rich
said look I'd love for you to just read
it and give me notes we are excited
about this thing we want to know if we
have anything on our hands and I trust
your opinion and so I said of course
whenever you're ready with the script
send it about a month and a half later
he called me said remember that script
know something about well it's done I'd
love to share with you and I read about
20 pages and they called it my brother
and I said Tim rich summer just sent me
the script and it is awesome it is so
fun
I'm so into this thing I'm gonna send it
to you now I'm gonna keep reading but
you should read it too and we read it
that night and you know rich was
expecting just to get notes back I don't
think he was expecting me to call him
back and say we want to produce it and I
also I want to direct it so I said look
rich I love this
I absolutely love this thing in every
way shape and form would you consider
not only us coming on to produce it but
would you be open to me directing this
thing I'd love to direct it I've been
looking for my next movie and rich you
know at that point I think he was
excited by the idea but wanted to talk
to Andy and so we all got together we
talked about it about what you know the
themes of the film and and why we wanted
to why I wanted to tell the story and
how and I think they felt comfortable
and we got together that's how we did
that
so I know you were part of a Ingrid goes
west as well another film that I loved
and in both films without giving away
too much about crooked somebody deal
with something that's very relevant
today and that is without going too deep
into it deserves just the the need for
notoriety I guess you could say and and
whether it's to speak out about
something that's very real and needs to
be addressed or on the other hand
there's all sorts of trickery involved
in today's landscape so and we're in
this new thing where we can't tell
what's real yet and sort of it's like
this trial by Twitter that were
essentially as a public engaging in yeah
so so I'm just curious what is that
something that's oh you know you've
you've grown up sort of near DC and as
you know it's a very different town than
LA in some ways maybe sometimes similar
what I would say to this question is I
think you're absolutely right I think
there are certainly parallels between
ingre goes west and crickets somebody in
terms of the character of Ingrid and the
character of Michael Vaughn you know to
people who need that affirmation that
you know they are of value of some sort
you know Michael Vaughn wants fame and
fortune it's what he's dreamt of but the
question why is a deeper question I
think the movie hopefully touches on
those reasons same with Ingrid I think
Ingrid is are really you know beneath
the surface of all the Instagram chats
and the fun kind of nature of the movie
I think there's a really honest
portrayal of someone who's sick the next
part of your question is yes it's a it's
a parent all over it's certainly
apparent in Washington DC that has no
reason why we wanted to tell these
movies in fact we typically you know we
love a good political movie as you can
tell by LBJ or the post for that matter
we grew up in DC I think those films
speak more to those instincts of ours
then Ingrid or crooked but but yeah we I
think maybe the proximity to where we
grew up to Washington DC maybe had
and influence on the kinds of stories we
want to tell I just don't know if I
would say that Ingrid and crooked were
were influenced by it okay going back to
West Hollywood the apartment and having
these industry jobs I'm wondering if you
can take us through each challenge you
had to overcome to start the production
company maintain it kind of like what
were those hurdles and then at some
point do you become a threat to other
production companies and you've got to
sort of protect yourself I mean there's
all these different things that happen
with growing pains yeah I mean the it's
hard to get into the specifics I don't
think our interview is nearly long
enough to go into the specifics of that
but there were certainly times that I
think Tim and I felt like our backs were
against the wall and there were times
where we thought about do we just throw
in the towel do we throw in the towel on
this thing and you know go find jobs
elsewhere which would have been a
perfectly suitable option it would have
been hard to accept I think just given
the amount of sweat and love we'd put
into this thing but but there was just
this belief this underlying belief that
we could do it we could pull this off
and we believed in our abilities to
develop good screenplays and to be able
to put movies together I think a little
blindly maybe finally ambitious because
if I were giving advice to someone in my
shoes you know 78 years ago I don't know
if I would tell them to do my path I
think it's a I think it's a hard path
and it requires just as much luck as it
does skill I think some people know
whether they're made to be and I don't
mean to have this be condescending but
employees whether they can they can take
a life of being a worker and whether
some people are just like I just can't
do that it's not that it's not honorable
I just can't do that and so if you're
willing to stay with the challenges and
I'm sure there was a lot of time when
you're spending alone and I know
entrepreneurship can become very
mm-hmm and in a sense that's basically
what it is even though it's in a
creative because really lucky to have my
brother as my partner on that you know
because at the time that we started the
company we were also living together and
so we had each other to really rely on
and and challenge I mean you know your
most honest with your family right so it
wasn't constantly oh this is great yes
we really challenged each other and I
think that made us better at the job and
you know I think for us I should speak
really for me because my brother is a
different person but I it didn't matter
to me the path it the result was far
more important I wanted to be making
movies I wanted to be directing movies I
wanted to be producing movies I wanted
to be a part of that process and to this
day it's the most gratifying thing I
could ever dream of I can't imagine I'll
ever fall out of love with this job how
do you balance your duties with the
films with your brother like is he good
at one thing and vice versa well we you
know there's a couple of us at the
company and you know I think it's the
the balancing of time I think is the
hardest part because there's never
enough time to do everything you want to
do and I think you know there's no world
in which you're gonna say all right
these are two or three projects and
that's all I'm focusing on I'm going to
put all my energy into these two or
three projects and expect those two or
three projects to happen it's just
unrealistic you know for us it's about
having more quantity still quality but
but having the ability to go out and try
to package several things and get out
there because not everything's gonna
work and the marketplace won't won't
deem everything a project of value so
it's about how do we keep
ideas coming into the company and having
the time to read them read the books
read the articles the scripts meet with
the writers of simultaneously prepping a
movie shooting a movie posting a movie
so and sometimes you know the case of
Ingrid and crooked they were overlapping
and so it can be challenging what do you
want people to take from crooked
somebody I know you had said off-camera
that there were some interesting
character arcs those are without giving
away too much of the ending but it
there's a very sort of surprising look
at good and bad yeah there is I think
what drew me to the two kind of key
figures in the movie was that their
character arcs kind of move in reverse
order and unexpectedly and I thought
that was really unique but what do I
want people to get out of this it's
funny in my first movie and jamesy boy I
really wanted it to be like this
emotional punch and I think I tried for
that and I might have missed the mark a
little bit on it so with this I really
wanted to not have that weight and I
just wanted this to be a fun time I
wanted you to not know where the story
was going and to just enjoy the entire
experience of watching it and that was
kind of the number one focus as making
it not trying to do too much or say too
much but just provide entertainment and
you know jury's out on it we we did that
for any of the titles that you've been
attached to whether it's as a producer
director what is your process for
getting people attached from crew talent
it's a great question and I can tell you
that every film that I've been a part of
has had a different everything slightly
different but I can tell you the most
traditional path that we look at and
that we try to implement and that's
start with the idea right so there's an
idea that's either hatched in house or
from a writer that we want to work with
the writer that we know
will mesh with our sensibilities we hire
that writer we collaborate with them you
know that process can be anywhere from
six months to a year sometimes longer
than a year depending on how much work
is needed to get the script into the
right place when the script is ready
then we go out to the you know talent
agencies and we have the actors of our
dream we have the directors of our dream
if I'm not direct you know we look at
who are the filmmakers out there that
could really do this film justice
simultaneously we're looking at the
budget you know because we have to think
about what does this film want to be
made for what should it be made for what
can it be made for they're all very
different things and so there's a range
and you know something we look at is if
a movie is scalable in that sense right
is there a version of this movie that is
great at 10 million but the same script
with different people involved
could it be made for 25 million so we
look at that and we think about all of
those factors and then we approach the
filmmakers the talent the actors the
director usually its director first and
then we bring on actors with in
conjunction with the directors thoughts
and then then we have a package and we
go get money you know and there's many
different sources for how you do that
sometimes the money comes to you which
is nice and then you go make a movie and
that's the point where you know you
start hiring all your key positions and
the more and more we make the more
relationships weaves you know part Cree
crew that we want to bring from another
movie back onto this one because we've
built relationships there we trust the
trust is there and then oftentimes we
work with new collaborators and that's
exciting as well and then the movie
wraps and then we see it all through
post-production through the editorial
and visual effects and sound design and
scoring and then it's about getting the
movie out there to the world if it's an
independent without distribution its
festivals and who are the right buyers
and that's sort of route and if it's a
studio film like the post you go into
production new in your start date you go
in knowing where it's going when it's
going and and how it's going so they're
two different pieces lastly what do you
see mistakes as new directors make
whether they're overly eager on set
they're nervous are afraid to approach
cast and crew what are some of the
mistakes whether they were ones that you
made in the beginning or that you just
see from other people that are green so
to speak I think the best advice I would
give to a filmmaker than a first-time
filmmaker that I'm working with is you
got to this point because you have a
clear vision stay true to that vision
and I think it's very easy with running
over budget or actors not wanting to do
things certain ways and the challenges
of actually physically making the movie
can get in the way of accomplishing that
vision and so as you begin to make
compromises it's important to keep that
in mind and I think young filmmakers
often veer from it and then they lose
the tone and the feel of their film so
that's kind of the best advice I would
give you know you have such an
incredible body of work like all the
films that you've been involved with I
haven't seen jamesy boy forgive me I
would like to see it but I mean they're
all films that I would recommend to
other people are you very selective with
what you take on it you have a great
body of work we thank you we're far more
selective now than we were I think at
the start of like any company you need
you need projects you need to be making
stuff you need to feed the the animal
now we're fortunate enough to be in a
position where you know we are
incredibly selective we won't you know
we could have five movies come that say
will you come on to this and produce it
there go movies they're happening I I
don't think we would jump onto those
unless we absolutely love it and feel
like we provide value to the project you
know I think we tend to want to be more
actively involved in a project than
passively so I think you know hence why
we like to develop our own material why
we like to kind of control it and
control how the movie comes together and
then sometimes the movie kind of goes
out of your hands a bit but comes
together miraculously like the post
which was you know for someone who
idolized as an understatement as a kid
seems feel boring I you know had a
poster of him on my wall it was the
dream of a lifetime getting to sit
beside him as he directed and watch him
and learn from him so you know there are
always fun moments involved I know the
post is a film that is very timely right
now yeah won't go into some of the
reasons why but you talk about making it
and just the process of seeing it sure
well when we started developing that
script with Liz Hanna we didn't know
that the film was gonna be as relevant
as it became you know this is pre the
election it was actually at a time when
we thought we were gonna have our first
female president and we thought this is
a movie that's about female empowerment
and about a woman finding her voice and
we thought it was relevant in that way
little did we know that it was about to
be relevant in a whole nother way and I
think what was amazing about that and
and you know we still have to pinch
ourselves that had happened in the way
that it did is most movies don't you
know get greenlit I have a start date
two months later with a release date six
months after that in time for Oscar
season you know so it was very much when
it when the green light came it was a
kind of a stunning moment seeing it may
be that the in a big theatre just with
the cast and crew the first time I saw
was actually in a small theatre I saw it
at Amblin at Steven's office in his
private screening
and it was I mean it's just one of the
most incredible experiences I think of
my life especially in my career just
watching this thing that you know we
spent every day watching how Steven
worked and where his mind was going with
decisions and then seen it so
effortlessly and beautifully come
together and and then to see our company
name up there and their credits it was
just like this is a dream this is a
childhood dream never thought it would
happen so it was emotional how did you
attach Steven spielberger how did you
approach him well I should say we didn't
you know the script had kind of taken on
a life of its own and had become quite a
popular script in town and at that point
there were many buyers involved that
wanted it and wanted to take it off the
table and it ultimately went to Amy
Pascal who you know was in her new post
as a producer after having run Sony for
a long time
and Amy was incredibly gracious and
collaborative and couldn't have been a
better partner on the project and with
Amy we then set it up at Fox and then
together it was one of these questions I
remember the first time we talked about
directors and Stephen siller's name came
up and it was he's doing another movie
and he's a that's the long shot of all
long shots so we kind of just didn't
think about it and then Amy received an
incoming call that said Stephens movie
is gonna push and Tom and Meryl we want
to send it to all three of them at the
same time and it was on a Friday
afternoon that we got that call and by
Monday all three had read it and wanted
to do it
what was that weekend like
actually not bad because we thought it
was so far-fetched wit we didn't think
it was in the realm of possibility I
mean we get calls all the time on
projects of Oh so-and-so let's send it
to them and you know and nine out of ten
times it doesn't pan out so I think we
never thought that the Monday call was
going to come the way it did so the I
didn't think about it much of that
weekend but then when we heard it it was
like a you know took your breath away